you've been very focused on rebuilding
this bridge between the Pentagon and
silicon valley you've got 16 more months
in this administration what will be
tangible proof that your outreach is
working what do you want to accomplish
in 16 a few things and I can do a lot in
16 months I'm a man in a hurry and 16
months is a long time as you know in
technology and I can start a lot even if
it'll go on as I hope it does after
while I'm gone so to get answer your
question give you some examples we're
making important investments and
technology in partnership with Silicon
Valley companies I'm going to announce a
major such initiative today in the area
of essentially flexible integrated
circuits which is a very important thing
so we'll be making investments private
public partnerships and direct
investments as we have for decades going
back to the ear of jet engines and
satellite communications right up
through the internet integrated circuits
so we need to be a technology leader to
protect our country and we can be a PEC
technology leader only if we partner
with folks out here and the other thing
is people I need good people who are
dedicated to our mission which is
protecting our country and making a
better world and they're looking out
here for interesting problems things
that are consequential these are people
who want to make them a difference in
life and there's nothing more
consequential than being part of
protecting people you're a physicist by
background so you understand this stuff
what are some key technologies and
assets that you can get from Silicon
Valley that you're not getting from
current defense contractors a lot of the
really new really cutting-edge brand-new
stuff we we do get but I find that the
Defense Department over the years has
gotten a little too bureaucratic a
little too slow for the pace of people
out here plus some of these people
didn't grow up as i did in a near where
all of our technology mentors had been
part of the world war two effort of the
coal
war effort and it was kind of in our
blood to take an interest in these
things so both on the people level some
of them aren't acquainted with us and
what we do and some of our people have
never understood the VC community or the
technology community we need to get them
to understand one another and in the
technology area we have so much to learn
from the cutting edge out you remember
we don't build anything in the Pentagon
we count in this country upon private
industry and private initiative to
create the technologies that next to the
wonderful people in uniform who make our
military the finest fighting force that
air the world has ever seen next to them
technologies what made us great and we
need that too so Google for example
they've been buying a number of robotics
companies they've got a humanoid robot a
cheetah robot a dog climbing robot when
are we going to see robot soldiers when
are we going to see self-driving cars in
the field on a mask I think you'll see
them soon we all already have tella
operated planes so-called drones
helicopters of the things undersea
vehicles true autonomy is another step
for it I just came from a briefing by a
set of advisors to be on technology you
have been studying all summer the
question of autonomy an autonomous
vehicle so you'll see them driving
underwater and doing all sorts of things
like patrolling cyber networks to defend
them all of those things will be done
autonomously or in very creative
man-machine combinations in the future
we need to be part of that revolution
much of it occurs right here and that's
another reason for my visit